[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  so do you know when you're learning a  piece it's very hard to resist that  temptation that urge to press forward  and approximate something and played in  tempo when you can't really play that at  all that's what I'm going through these  days and I'm just going to make note of  it because even though it's obvious it's  something that we should all be aware of  how easily bad habits can be formed in  that small period of time everything  from neglecting certain details to  learning things completely incorrectly  developing weird physical habits while  you're compensating for not really  knowing the piece and trying to play it  at full speed that is all  [Music]